♪ ♪
>> Tucker: KEITH ELLISON OF
MINNESOTA ISN'T SOME OBSCURE
SEAMLESS DEMOCRAT.
HE IS DEPUTY CHAIR OF THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMPANY.
HE NEARLY WON THE CHAIRMANSHIP
OUTRIGHT LAST YEAR.
HE IS A FAVORITE OF THE
GRASSROOTS.
HE DESERVES TO BE REGARDED AS
THEY ARE.
YESTERDAY, ELLISON TWEETED THIS.
AT MOON PALACE BOOKS, I JUST
FOUND A BOOK THAT WILL STRIKE
FEAR IN THE HEART OF
DONALD TRUMP'S HEART.
THE BOOK HE WAS TALKING ABOUT,
"ANTIFA: THE ANTI-FASCIST
HANDBOOK."
BUY WITH THAT BOOK STRIKE FEAR
MAYBE BECAUSE THAT BOOK
ADVOCATES FOR POLITICAL VIOLENCE
AGAINST PEOPLE LIKE DONALD TRUMP
AND HIS SUPPORTERS.
THE AUTHOR IS AN    MAN NAMED MR
THE AUTHOR IS AN    MAN NAMED MK
GREG.
"A SMALL THOUGH VITAL SLIVER OF
ANTIFASCIST ACTIVITY."
ELSEWHERE IN THE TEXT, HE
APPROVINGLY QUOTES AN ANTI- --
"YOU FIGHT THEM WITH KNIVES YOU
DON'T HAVE TO FIGHT THEM WITH
GUNS.
YOU FIGHT THEM WITH GUNS SO YOU
DON'T HAVE TO FIGHT THEM WITH
TANKS."
THAT IS ABOUT AS EXPLICIT A
JUSTIFICATION FOR POLITICAL
ENDORSES THE TACTIC OF SILENCING
THOSE HE DOESN'T AGREE WITH.
OF COURSE, BRAY CLAIMS TO FIGHT
KEITH ELLISON FINDS HIS WORK
ADMIRABLE.
HE SAID SO.
IF YOU ARE SHOCKED BY THIS, YOU
HAVEN'T FOLLOWED ELLISON'S
CAREER FOR HIM.
HE HAS A HISTORY OF BACKING
REPUGNANT THINGS.
HE WROTE THAT THE CONSTITUTION
EXISTED ONLY FOR WHITE PEOPLE.
HE REFERRED TO IT AS "FAIR"
CONSTITUTION, CALLING IT "A
CONSPIRACY TO SUBJUGATE OTHER
PEOPLE'S."
ELLISON HAS SPOKEN FAVORABLY OF
POPULAR.
HE SAID HE WAS "PRAYING THAT
FIDEL CASTRO'S COMMUNIST REGIME
IN CUBA WOULD NOT BE FORCED TO
AS A LOSS TO IT ELLISON WROTE A
STATE.
THIS IS THE MAN THAT IS NOW
SECOND IN COMMAND OF IN TERRA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THAT OUGHT TO BOTHER REPUBLICANS
AND INDEPENDENCE.
IT SHOULD TERRIFIED -- MOST
DON'T SUPPORT KILLING, RACIAL
SEPARATISM, ABOLISHING FREEDOM
THAT DO SUPPORT THOSE THINGS.
DEMOCRATS AT THIS POINT ASSUME
THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE MAJOR
GAINS IN THIS YEAR'S MIDTERM
ELECTIONS PURELY ON THE STRENGTH
OF THE PRESIDENT'S POLL NUMBERS.
THEY ARE HAPPY TO IGNORE HATERS
LIKE KEITH ELLISON.
ELLISON OPPOSES TRUMP AND THAT
IS ENOUGH FOR NOW.
BUT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY DID WIN AND
GOT POWER BACK IN NOVEMBER?
SUDDENLY ELLISON'S VIEWS WOULD
MATTER A LOT.